it was
1973 nearly 50 years ago when the
supreme court issued roe versus wade
that landmark decision determined the
constitution protects a woman's right to
an abortion at least in the first
trimester
now the case struck down many state and
federal abortion laws that were
considered to cause an undue burden but
that ruling was not the final word this
morning we're going to go to the cbs
news archives to review the history of
roe v wade and the conflict that has
lasted for decades
hundreds of thousands of women married
and unmarried are desperately seeking to
end their pregnancies
i figure that i have one child i should
do the best i can for that child rather
than having two not being able to i
don't feel very good about it but it's
something i had to do
a child in the womb
has rights
and needs the protection of law in a
landmark ruling the supreme court today
legalized abortions other opponents are
now talking of a constitutional
amendment to reverse today's ruling
[Music]
we gather here today on the first
anniversary of one of the blackest days
in the history of american jewish
prudence
i think the pro-life movement is kind of
flexing its muscles murder is murder
when a teenager here in indiana decides
she wants an abortion but can't tell her
parents she generally makes the 110 mile
trip to kentucky she died a result of a
botched illegal abortion people in
general are going to start voting
on abortion we are simply telling the
awful truth that little baby boys and
girls are being dismembered keep your
hands off our right to choose
while many have condemned this campaign
to frighten doctors and clinic directors
the truth is said one doctor today
it's working
abortion has long been a sensitive issue
in this country it has divided americans
for decades and has recently sparked
intense debate over organizations like
planned parenthood the suspect in the
deadly siege of a planned parenthood
clinic is due in a few hours to make his
first court appearance threats of
violence and actual violence against the
justices of core strike at the heart of
our democracy
do you want to see the court overturn
wrong if we put another two or perhaps
three justices on that's really what's
going to be that's will happen roe v
wade
is an important precedent of the supreme
court
oklahoma is the latest state to move
closer to restricting abortion access i
was raped
and i was 19. abortion is murder and i
feel that way period other states like
indiana nebraska are considering similar
laws 50 years of progress being undone
will not be accepted spreading fallout
from that stunning and stunning is a
word supreme court leak of a draft
opinion that suggests that roe v wade is
set to be overturned
[Music]
and there you have it here we are in
2022 the history is long when you look
at how long we've been discussing the
people thought that this day would never
happen it seemed unthinkable and yet
here we are
nearly a 50-year fight to get to this
moment now people are saying it's going
to be another 50-year fight for there to
be a change people also talk about
minority rule about unelected judges
we've got 80 million people who don't
vote at all this is the result